Fire!
Hello there, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
And welcome to this lovely
4k Slow Mo Guys video.
We're going to be injecting ink into water
and filming it's prettiness.
Hopefully we'll get some nice silking.
We got a few different colors
and a full tank of water.
Sorry.
We're gonna film this
on the Phantom Flex 4k.
We got some lovely white backgrounds
that Dan taped to a tree
and a tank of water.
So we got some different variants of ink.
We got some pearlescent ones,
sort of metallic-looking.
Little bits of glitter.
This one looks cute doesn't it?
Look at all it, it's
watery, but look how...
It seems like the thicker ones
Look how glittery it is.
look better in the water
because they kind of blend less.
Yeah, it takes longer for them to mix in
with the rest of the water,
so they sort of keep
their shape, looks cool.
I think this turquoise one's
gonna look really good.
All right, what color is this Daniel?
Yellow.
Try some yellow ink.
Yep.
All right, you know where you're doing it?
Yeah.
Okay, it's good.
Ready?
Yep.
Oh, nice.
Delectable that is.
That's gorgeous isn't it, look at that.
Cool.
That is glory.
Look at that.
It's perfect.
I'd like to do that again...
That's "silkenhime."
Look at that, look at the
light play on the uh...
"Light play."
The light's playing on
the surface of the ink,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Almost like--
You got some air in that--
That's what it is, it's air rising up.
Pulling the ink with it.
Oh, cool.
So now we embark on the
very lengthy process
of refilling the tank.
This is the longest
set up for this shot...
Yeah.
... for what we do for many
other shots to be honest.
This is probably the longest setup.
It's always annoying
when the actually action,
you know, is .5 of a second.
Huh.
And the reset is like 15 minutes.
What I'd rather do is do all
of these as separate elements.
Separate elements?
At the same exposure,
and then I can just
overlay them on each other.
Oh, that's a good idea.
Coming in from like
different angles and that.
Yeah, that's cool.
Yeah?
Yeah.
That's good.
"Silkshua."
Oh lovely.
Okay, so I'm gonna get about
half a tablespoon of this ink.
"Half a tablespoon."
There you go.
Oh, look at that.
Lovely.
Oh.
That's some good ink.
Lovely.
Look at that.
That is just deluxe , isn't it?
That's beautiful.
Look how silky that is.
So, come from,
you want to probably blast that way
from where your finger is now, so.
Maybe like, yeah.
There.
And...
Fire.
Wicked.
Aw, look at that.
That looked really good.
That's cool.
That's awesome.
That's really good.
I approve.
Hey, well done us.
I think that was one of
the best looking videos
we've ever made.
Yeah, it's one of my favorites.
So cool.
Just watching all the silky
clouds, just kinda like
Yeah, some of the colors
didn't really work so well,
like the reds didn't look--
This blue was by far
the favorite one for me.
Yeah, that was awesome.
Yeah.
Thanks for watching that video.
Be sure to follow us on Twitter.
Get a T-shirt.
Get a T-shirt, and that
and subscribe.
We make slow mo all the time,
don't we.
Yeah.
Flippin-A.
My eyes.
Oh, man.
What the hell are you doing?
What do I do if there's ink in my eye?
You really...
You've got it in your hair and your eye.
Aw man.
Oh, that's horrible.
I didn't know your bloody neck
is such a bouncy surface.
It came right back at me.
What color is that do you think?
Turquoise isn't it?
Baby blue...
Baby blue.
Twitter bird blue.
It is Twitter bird blue,
that's cute isn't it?
That's nice.
That's me doing the twitter noise.
Oh, good impression.
Nah, that's too much .
I recon .
That way you get .
It's like this, it's .
Like that.